[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's go to Kevin he's in Houston Texas
what's going on Kevin let's make it a
quick Oney how you doing doing good how
are you pleasure to finally talk to you
guys you too so I I'll make it short and
simple um I just paid off like $10,000
in credit card debt I'm on baby step
number two good for you so my next uh
loan to attack is my truck loan okay and
it's my only thing I have left but it's
a high one it's
around $83,000 left whoa it used to be
94 it used to be 94,000 but now it's at
83 because I make extra payments what
kind of truck is this this is a souped
up Ford F250 Lariat is it for
work purposes uh no it's just pure
luxury I'm one of those that just has a
truck for luxury I don't pull nothing
how much do you make a year Kevin
wanted um I make about 14,000 a month
okay yeah gave or take like sometimes it
could be 10 12 14 depends how much I
want to work I'm selling
it yeah I'm selling it I would Kevin the
$83,000 in a truck that's that has debt
that's going down in value that you're
paying interest
on wow yeah it it took me like a while
to get it cuz it was like I had to
pre-order it I believe it I'm sure you
did yeah I bet and uh so I do want to
add it to the to the dead snowball but I
just I'm trying to figure out how to go
about it if I should just pay more every
month or just save up one giant no no
you want to be paying on it yes as as
you get extra cash flow you're throwing
it at the truck but we would I mean I
would run the numbers Kevin I would
Kelly Blue Book it run a scenario look
on craigslist look at you know local
dealerships for other trucks and just
for a for a second just think oh my gosh
cuz how much is your
payment it's about 1,700 a month oh Lord
sell it Kevin Kevin Kevin run the
numbers okay go to Ramsey solutions.com
and pull up our investment calculator if
you invested
$1,700 a month if you invested that
Kevin do you know how much money you
would have I wish I had my computer on I
would do it right now my go I'm a
skeleton I'm dead I am just wow and do
you have other debt besides this or is
this going to be it this is it this is
really my only payment I have a month is
because all all my other expenses are
paid for so
wow Rachel you keep the conversation
going I'll do the investment calculator
you got to go we got like we got 30
seconds okay I would I mean Kevin I I'm
not going to sit here and like convince
you you're you're a grown man you can do
what you want but but our biggest goal
is that we want your money working for
you not against you there are so much of
your income and hard you you make
incredible money I mean if 150 to 160 a
year that actually be Building Wealth
for your family you could actually be
changing your legacy and building your
wealth with this versus sending it to uh
where Ford Motor Company or wherever it
is going right so so there's there's
power and letting your money work for
you versus it working for a car
dealership and that's what you're doing
right now with this truck wow if you if
you did 1,700 a month two
$2,225 after 25 years 25 years you could
have $2 million this is the Ramsey
Show create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life